european union ministers responsible for
energy policy have agreed on new rules
to make the use of biofuels in the eu
more sustainable
and so help cut greenhouse gas emissions
it means the council's established its
position on so-called
indirect land use change this is when
farmland is used to produce biofuels
leading to food or feed being grown in
other areas like forests
which results in more carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere
the aims to minimize the environmental
impact of indirect land use
and encourage more advanced biofuels
onto the market
thanks to this common position this
means that in our forthcoming
negotiations with the european
parliament
we can start negotiations on the second
reading of the italian presidency
energy prices were also up for
discussion the ministers examined ways
to strengthen the role
rights and awareness of consumers
preventing the unfair disconnection of
people's electricity was also an area of
concern
energy security in europe in particular
avoiding any major disruption in
supplies next winter and the conflict in
ukraine
was debated too russia is the eu's
biggest natural gas supplier
much of which transits through ukraine
the two countries are locked in a gas
price dispute that simmered for several
years and hit supplies
into europe in the past